from the one successful director who
turned his own name until box-office
poison comes the poorly directed lazily
written terribly shot poorly acted
clumsily edited oddly paced insulting
adaptation of The Last Airbender
improperly converted 3d prepare for the
vibrant world of Nickelodeon's beloved
avatar to get M night upon in the worst
cartoon adaptation since Dragonball
Evolution watch as the ethnically
diverse heroes you know and love are
brought to life as generic white kids
and the ethnically diverse villains stay
at nicly diverse wander in amazement at
how 150 million dollar movie ended up
with some of the worst special-effects
ever put to film
scenes that weren't lit properly
and unknown child actors who are bad
even by child actor standards they
haven't been able to conquer big cities
like bossing say but they're making
plans I'm sure so are you the avatar
wrong
uh-oh these kids stayed in school
journey across four magical kingdoms
where a chosen few sort of have the
power to bend the elements to their will
firebenders who can't catch anything on
fire water vendors who can't get this
guy wet and earthbenders who could just
as easily pick up this rock and thrown
it but when the evil firebender Prince
Zuko goes on the warpath bring me all
your elderly humanity's last hope is a
boy who can master every element the
avatar oh man I wish no this pouty one
with all the henna tattoos doing his
green belt karate demonstration join
armed and to unnecessary sidekicks as
they struggle to cram 20 episodes of
backstory into one movie with techniques
like weird introductions
my name is Katara and I'm the only
waterbender left in the Southern Water
Tribe weird compliments you are a gifted
strategist your failure in the hundred
day siege of Ba Sing se won't be held
against you awkward toasts what thank
you
Sukho as you know fire lord is banished
his son the prince renounced his love of
it and a super-long Star Wars title
crawl you really should just
fast-forward through this car and maybe
even the whole movie starring this girl
this kid this other kid this dude who
cast this thing oh the guy from The
Daily Show and Slumdog Millionaire The
Last Airbender if you thought this was
bad where do you see after Earth so is
this the worst invite Shyamalan movie
help us decide by clicking our new
screen junkies episode respect my
authority there's always money in the
banana stand
flawless victory it's clobberin time
you're tearing me apart Lisa join me and
together we can rule the gah